I'm going to read two guys stats and I
want to know who you'd pick 35 12 6 and2
the other one
304 4 and three I'm going to go with the
uh 35 that is Joel embiid's season this
year and the second one was your best
season with the Lakers but you forgot
what I did that with four mother on me
he don't get double times that times
four I average 120 points mother he's
reached the point now where everyone
just says show it to me in the playoffs
I'm going to give it to him like Kareem
gave it to me he should take it as
disrespectful cuz that's how I took it
but later talking to Kareem I wasn't
being disrespectful I was being factual
I was averaging big numbers with LA and
this article really broke my heart they
ask Kareem what do you think about Shaq
and Kareem says well he hasn't won any
championships yet so that's my message
to Mr MB like we know what you can do
but can you do it at the big dance